well despite the sunshine and warmth of
the State of Florida Ron DeSantis is
experiencing significant shrinkage
in the polls even though he hasn't even
announced that he's running for
president in 2024 and he may not Ron
DeSantis over the last several weeks has
seen a pretty significant decline in the
polls which we're going to look at in a
moment why is this going on well there's
an interesting article in the week by
Raffi Schwartz and it looks like looks
at a couple of different aspects to this
and one of the things that this article
mentions
quotes political consultant and
commentator Simon Rosenberg who says
that the successes that DeSantis has had
in Florida are actually alienating him
from voters in background Battleground
States still stinging from Republican
losses by the candidates who embraced
the right most reaches of the political
Spectrum Schwartz writes it's into this
Dynamic that DeSantis has quote decided
to become even more Maga super Maga the
end result is that for Republicans
hoping DeSantis would be a reasonable
and capable alternative to Trump this
has been a very bad week that is one
perspective that actually he is he is
going Beyond Maga it's too much Maga for
Maga and the voters in Battleground
States aside from whatever Floridian
Republicans say about DeSantis aren't
super thrilled I think that that's one
part of it
secondly the idea of DeSantis was very
appealing as an alternative to Trump six
to eight months ago but increasingly as
DeSantis is more publicly visible he
just was interviewed by Piers Morgan
we're going to look at clips from that
his lack of Charisma and his complete uh
we'll leave it there his lack of
Charisma is starting to become apparent
to voters who are sort of being deflated
by that they were excited about the
santis now they've seen what the sand
this is really like and they're like I
don't know this isn't really that great
uh the hill reports desantisi's lowest
level of support since December in new
poll
Trails Trump by 28 points and in fact
there are a number of polls that are
really not looking good for DeSantis
there is a BC rated premise poll which
has Trump up 24 uh with registered
voters there
um is a yougov poll that has Trump up
15. there is a Monmouth poll in uh that
has Trump up 52 certainly a difficult
one to believe I have to say but that
that's what it says
um a morning consult poll has Trump up
28 that's the one that was referenced it
it's really not looking good here for
Ron DeSantis so the question we were
previously asking with Donald Trump was
can Trump make it to the primary
insofar as indictments could derail him
or whatever else might be the case with
DeSantis the question is less about can
you make it to the primaries it can even
make it into the race now I've
previously talked about what some of you
have suggested which is DeSantis is
really young
um yeah
why not just wait why not just wait
until 2028 he doesn't have to run right
now Trump won't be a factor no matter
what happens in 2028 maybe 48 or 49 year
old DeSantis should look at running in
a month ago my view was he's not going
to be able to look at the polling
numbers and get away because he would be
saying to himself I might not have this
opportunity in 28 as the numbers decline
for DeSantis maybe 28 starts to look
more attractive now what one other thing
I would love to say that DeSantis is
dangerous authoritarian Tendencies are
the reason why he's failing in the polls
but Trump has all of those same
authoritarian Tendencies so that's not
actually what it is I I do think that
there is something to the idea of
DeSantis is becoming the reality of
DeSantis and a lot of people don't
really like it so Trump aside DeSantis
is dangerous DeSantis is doing better
against uh Biden than Trump is doing so
in a sense it's probably good for the
left for DeSantis not to do well in the
primary on the other hand DeSantis
bailing
might make Trump's path easier which has
its own downsides in that he may end up
in the general election less weakened
and sort of more ready to go but that a
lot of things are going to happen
between now and when the general
election starts so shrinkage for Ron
DeSantis let's now talk about a story
that is bringing together Trump and
DeSantis which is very very interesting